qui a dit selon vous j'ai vraiment pensé
à arrêter de vivre parce que je
comprenais pas pourquoi j'étais né dans
ce corps
c'est Christine and the Queen à nos
confrères de
[Applaudissements]
Paris
alors effectivement c'est la grande
Christine and the Queen que je trouve
exceptionnel et c'est vrai quel talent
extraordinaire maintenant toutes ces
transformations c'est plus comment
l'appeler même nous à la radio
on sait plus qu'on doit dire parce qu'on
veut vexer personne parce qu'un coup il
fallait plus l'appeler Christine and the
Queen fallait l'appeler red car ouais
après Chris maintenant tu sais qu'on est
revenu on vient de recevoir un nouveau
mot il faut la rappeler de nouveau
Christine and the Queen mais c'est
bizarre parce qu'elle l'a dit récemment
qu'à partir de ses 40 ans elle voudrait
il y a un nouveau nom qu'on appelle
Rahim
il voudrait pardon parce qu'en plus on
doit dire
il voudrait non il je me renseigner
avant de la recevoir à RFM mais j'avoue
que là je ne sais plus Francesca on peut
quand même dire que enfin moi je trouve
qu'il y a un truc triste dans tout ce
problème d'identité là pour le coup il y
a pas une identité pour aller vers une
autre et être sûr là ça a changé plein
de fois donc donc je me dis au bout d'un
moment ça doit être même fatiguant pour
elle et d'ailleurs cette phrase elle est
très très triste je trouve et j'ai
l'impression que justement le fait que
ça change tout le temps qu'elle rechange
de nom à un moment donné il faut qu'elle
se trouve quoi parce que quand tu vas
dans une quête à un moment donné faut se
trouver allez être devenu un homme a été
savateur et libérateur vous le savez
qu'elle avait fait part de cette grande
décision en 2022 elle a décidé de
changer de sexe et de changer de nom de
scène pour être car une référence à son
quatrième album effectivement comme tu
dis Deborah il y a écrit sans suite elle
explique avant de faire de la musique
elle a eu des pensées suicidaires alors
est-ce que ça vous choque qu'elle ait
envie de tout cela ou pas Ludivine oui
moi je voulais rebondir ce que sur ce
que disait Francesca tout à l'heure moi
je pense pas que le fait qu'elle veuille
autant changer de nom soit totalement
liée et uniquement lié à son changement
de sexe moi j'ai des exemples comme pidi
qu'à traverser c'était falaise
un jour voilà un jour
Kanye West il y a eu beaucoup beaucoup
de d'artistes comme ça je pense que ça
peut également faire partie du processus
artistique
il y a une transformation de sexe
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas je suis
pas si intime que ça
je sais pas mais elle fait des photos
assez
je trouve juste dommage c'est que depuis
qu'elle s'est mis à parler ouvertement
de ça j'ai l'impression qu'on entend
plus du tout sa musique on entend plus
parler de musique on n'a pas à l'époque
quand elle avait sorti celle qu'on la
chanson qu'on a mis j'adore cette
chanson celle-là c'était elle était un
peu son apogée etc et puis après elle
s'est mise à porter un peu le drapeau de
de standards
et puis à ce moment là on a quasi plus
entendu parler de musique et on oui et
le dernier titre qui soit resté de ça le
dernier album était comme on dit plus
exigeant c'est-à-dire que la musique
était plus difficile d'accès
donc il y a tout un processus qui fait
qu'elle a perdu un petit peu trop de
tout ça moi j'ai j'ai le fils d'un ami
qui est d'une amie pardon qui a 9 ans
peu importe et qui était Marc sa
maîtresse il y a pas longtemps il y a 15
jours pour lui dire qu'il était amoureux
d'une petite fille et la maîtresse
gentiment lui a dit tu sais tu peux
aussi être amoureux d'un petit garçon et
c'est pas c'est pas choquant en soi
c'est qu'à un moment on a l'impression
qu'on parle tellement tout le temps de
ça non-stop on a réussi presque à mettre
dans la tête de tous nos enfants alors
je sais que je vais peut-être choqué en
disant ça pardon et je trouve que
l'évolution est très bonne et cetera que
quelque part on sait plus très bien que
limite se poser des questions c'est bien
on peut aussi être tout simplement
hétéro tout simplement gay l'assumer
enfin voilà et que certains ne se
trouvent pas je peux le comprendre
certains ont besoin de se faire opérer
pourquoi pas mais un monde c'est le
débat quotidien sur tous les sujets
aujourd'hui pratiquement voilà